Okay Herr Doktor.
Gibt es irgendwelche chronische Erkrankungen bei Ihrer Familie?
Ja, mein Vater leide an Leba-Tumor oder Leba Krebs gestorben vor 5 Jahren.
Tut mir leid zu hören. Wie alt war er?
Er war 68.
Ja, tut mir sehr leid.
Ihre Mutter?
Meine Mutter hat Bruttochdruck und Zuckerkrankheit und Knochen geschwunden.
Die Frauen leiden immer an Knochen geschwunden. Man muss beachten, Frau Müller.
Haben Sie Geschwister?
Ich habe keine Geschwister. Nein.
Sie sind ein Einzelkind.
Sind Sie vollständig geimpft?
Ja Herr Doktor. Ich bin vollständig geimpft.
Waren Sie in letzter Zeit im Ausland?
Nein Herr Doktor. Nein.
Ich möchte noch eine Frage stellen.
Ich habe vergessen zu sagen, vor 3 Jahren hatte ich Gürtelroset.
Vor 4 Jahren?
Vor 3 Jahren.
Wie wurde es behandelt?
Mit Medikamenten hatte ich die genommen. Aber es war sehr schmerzhaft Herr Doktor.
Verstehe.
Manchmal habe ich...
Im Rückenbereich?
Im Rücken und unter der Mutter. Links.
Unter der Brust.
Ich kenne diese Erkrankung. Es ist wirklich schmerzhaft.
Sie haben recht Frau Müller.
Ich möchte noch eine Frage stellen.
Haben Sie Schwellungen in irgendwelchen Körperregionen bemerkt?
Im Bauch oder in das Bein?
Nein. Ich habe keine Schwellungen Herr Doktor.
Gut. Meinerseits habe ich alle wichtigen Fragen gestellt. Möchten Sie noch etwas hinzufügen?
Ja Herr Doktor. Ich habe Angst natürlich. Was kann ich haben? Was habe ich?